the green fur the gyrating belly the  party horn knows this is philly fanatic  mascot for the philadelphia phillies  the philly's mascot is maybe the  wackiest of them all at least in the mlb  but it wasn't always that way  in the 1970s the phillies had  philadelphia phil and philadelphia  phyllis a pair of mascots straight out  of the 18th century and they were well  boring  so the phillies pivoted they  commissioned bonnie and wade two muppet  makers who had worked alongside puppet  mastermind jim henson  the phillies decided to create a  family-friendly attention-grabbing  mascot and on april 25th 1978 the philly  fanatic made his triumphant debut all  six feet of green fur made its way out  onto the field to roaring applause  38 years later the big green atv riding  super circle wielding fanatic is still  making the crowds go wild  to all you phillies fans give it up for  the philly fanatic  you